think big but start small have that big
vision for where you're gonna go with
your business to help keep you motivated
but make sure you're taking steps every
day to move that business forward
otherwise it's all you have is a big
dream sometimes it's so big and so scary
that you don't end up taking any action
to move it forward hi I'm Evan
Carmichael your friend in all things
entrepreneurship and today I'm answering
a question from one of our readers
Jennifer who wants to start a children's
amusement park and is worried that she
only has the option to start big so
thanks for the question Jennifer
congratulations I wanted to start this
business
I'm I'm worried for you it's possible to
start big it's possible to raise a lot
of money and start big but your chances
of success go down dramatically because
you're gonna make a lot of mistakes like
with any business you're gonna make a
lot of mistakes and the more money and
the more you grow the more opportunities
there are for mistakes the best way to
build a business if you can is start
small and build it up and so applying
that to your business how can you do it
you don't have to have a huge amusement
park wrecked in the beginning what I
would do is try to find low-cost ways to
get this thing started I would try to
partner up with local events that are
happening and bring one or two rides out
I would partner up with shopping malls
and use their parking lots on special
days where you can bring some of your
rides out I would try to find cheap ways
to get started it does a couple things
one it helps you test the market do
people want what you're selling it's
great idea to think about it right so
yeah of course everybody wants it but
you never actually know until you start
selling it'll help you see if you
actually like doing this business right
again it can look great on paper but
until you're in it you don't actually
know if you're gonna enjoy this business
or not so
help guide you and they'll start
bringing some money if you can start
bringing in someone and get to the point
where you're at least paying some bills
off at home it's it releases a lot of
stress and a lot of tension allows you
to build a platform for growth so I want
you to have that big vision but find a
lower-cost way to test it out and get
started because I'm afraid that you have
this big dream but nothing is actually
ever gonna happen because it's too big
if you think I have to start big it's
the only way to do it chances are you're
not gonna end up doing anything and
that's my fear for you with my business
my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs it's a big number I don't
quite know how exactly that's gonna
happen and we've helped almost 20
million entrepreneurs now through the
website getting to a billion is a big
number that motivates me to keep going
but doesn't paralyze me with fear I'm
still able to do things every day that
grow that business if you look at
companies like harley-davidson and look
at how they got started it was started
by two friends one of them Harley went
in Davidson and they built their first
bike in a shed in their backyard and the
first year they had one bike and the
next year they had three bikes and the
next year they had another three bikes
and the next year they had another seven
bikes and then they started to grow a
little too big for their shed so they
created their own little mini factory
and they kept growing little by little
every year taking those steps and
eventually became one of the most well
known motorcycle companies in the world
they had a big vision but it started
small they took steps and and it doesn't
have to take you years to do it but by
testing it out on a small scale making
partnerships with local businesses
finding ways to get started cheaply and
not spending a lot of money to to test
your concept see if you enjoy doing this
or not and then also start bringing in
some money is in my opinion a much
better way to get started than to try to
act
right from the start my two cents good
luck with the business for those of you
watching if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up below I'd also love
to hear we have to think if you want to
leave a comment under the video thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode
you